i don't remember about the time trying
to keep it cool
look at her
straight up she said wow is it
[Music]
my neck is killing me bro you need to
see someone about that boo you need to
get yourself an anti-inflammatory thing
anti-inflammatory yeah the cream thing
oh like a mussel sauce oh yeah i think
you can get like
like ibuprofen creams or something
something ridiculous like that or like a
heat pad or some [ __ ]
you need scientific i'm too g for this i
find that though
i don't know what you mean too solid
[Laughter]
i know exactly what you mean
i'll just let the things run its course
yeah fam i'm just i just hurt until it
stops
yeah let my body do what i need to do
yes yeah calm
but yeah anyway guys
happy monday yo what's good with it
i hope you're feeling blessed um on this
lovely day and yeah man
it's one two one thing
she wants a couple man from brom
gala get bang obviously um
whatever else is birmingham related i
don't know
um
but yeah man obviously guys you know the
drill
scoring on over to patreon that's
patreon.com forward slash [ __ ] in gigs
um
and then um
yeah man positing patreon.com forward
slashes and gigs if you want to jump
onto an extra 50 percent of the content
no extra 100 really
you're missing out on 50 that's what i
meant to say double the content man so
when you're doing those long lonely
drives guys you already know what to do
when you're binging it out on a monday
or a tuesday whenever you you check out
the episode and you think [ __ ] i've got
to go the whole of the week before i can
get some more juicy juice big man you're
cutting yourself short head on over head
on over and get the up-to-date juicy
juice patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs that's the way to go okay
while you're over there
make your way over
and get some merch okay links are all in
the descriptions links are everywhere
jump on that merch your boy fuegs is
hitting up that tequila sip sip today
you know what it is if you don't know
what sips it is definitely head over to
patreon
um missing out yeah they fly off over
there
and uh guys if you're here on the
youtube front make sure you snuggle up
up next that like button just give that
a clickety clack if you're interested if
you're single trying to mingle chirps or
thing in the comments
um yeah let's we're we're a cult at the
end of the day and a cult needs to
spread its wings and have its own
breeding facilities okay so
we're trying to have
have people breeding up in a tank so we
need as many
bonds formed before we head on over to
start our cult in like utah or somewhere
somewhere empty somewhere somewhere like
passive
um so yeah chap sitting in the comments
um i see a lot of guys shooting a shot
out there
girls get involved as well um i saw a
nice female do it yesterday though i saw
that as well yeah yeah she knows who she
is um
and then um guys what you've liked so
now you've you've paused it right you've
pressed the like button
you've chopped something in the comments
bear replies
um
now
click subscribe if you haven't already
it's a big red button go on over click
subscribe and turn the bell notification
on as well man that's that's just how it
needs to be done
um and yeah man
without further ado
you're sitting here with your boy
jimmy moolah
fire lord for eggs fire lord for eggs
the dragon of the west is about to hit
you up with some fun facts so buckle up
let's enjoy the episode let's have a fun
[ __ ] monday yeah let's get into it
let's go
now gas now i'm gas now let's go
spit that fire flakes
don't sweep me don't sweep me
so
do you remember when i asked you um i
wonder where
they're gonna take technology next and
like um apple and blah blah you said
something to me something to me about
translation earbuds the earbuds yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so did you know
there's a bread that's already created
it called dannymoo
dannymoo yeah danny sorry danny manu
no i didn't know that so i saw the other
uh i said it's already over this thing i
saw that last week but i saved it for a
nap so a ghanaian british entrepreneur
has now developed wireless earbuds that
can instantly translate 40 to 40
different languages
danny manu a ghanian british man
developed earbuds that auto translates
up to other languages according to keep
the faith the ear buds can
live translate over 40 languages the
product called click is said to be the
world's first 3d wireless earphones with
live voice translation support in 40
languages the wireless bluetooth headset
works by pairing to a smartphone the
earbuds then automatically detect the
language being spoken and provide a
spoken translation within a sentence or
two
click does not require internet like
similar inventions
it doesn't require internet
so that was when i saw but that's when i
saw the
um
the fact that i actually googled
him himself i've
just come off it randomly so he's
actually his own website called
mymanu.com
i think these are earbuds called clicks
yeah
they don't require
internet internet i don't know how that
pattern's done
it must
it's all saved in the thing what's going
on it can't be just save
that doesn't that's suspicious bruv what
do you mean it doesn't use internet i
don't know i guess that's interesting
though that is very interesting
that is very interesting um considering
it's
something that's already readily
available i'm surprised this isn't like
blown
so why aren't going for the google ones
bravo because did it do they work or not
i don't know bro
how much 160 quid is it
pretty cheap considering interesting
earbuds are like the same price roughly
130. yeah or airpods rather
i'm intrigued by these bro same i'm
intrigued can you imagine oh so awkward
though obviously
i don't know what you expect but you
almost want to be instant in it yeah
when it says a sentence or two you're
disappointed and then man are just like
and you have to wait and you're like
okay yes it's like
i said yes
it's like when you
watch um live tv with subtitles and the
thing he comes up afterwards after
they've spoken let's say like text yeah
they're speaking speaking speaking
they're on like sentence three and it's
only come up with sentence one bro
with that teletext font the teletext
font in different colors fam they're
different clothes and then you've got
the lady in the sideline just just doing
gang signs yeah
just doing [ __ ] in things
and you're just fixed i don't know too
much information yeah that's there [ __ ]
going on
yeah ma'am
mad
that's i'm surprised that that's not
like
gone spread like global yeah i'm
surprised that's not wildfire yeah
someone's playing saxophone in the
office next door bro um
it's getting louder
[Music]
that was weird
it sounded like a pup
or a fly like stuck somewhere yeah
anyway [ __ ] oh man um
yeah i just don't get it bro i feel
there's a catch also i'm not a massive
fan of the fact that he called his
website mymanu.com what's that got to do
with the brand my g
true take yourself out of the equation
you should have called it like click.com
yeah i don't like man like that i don't
like manufacturing
i don't like man
is too big for the creation
i said my manu that don't make sense get
your name out of the tank
i don't feel like anyone i'm trying to
think is there any business that well
there has definitely but apart from like
typical like retail stores and stuff
like that
there's no like real global business
that's like bait someone started by
basing it on their own name
um that's a back of dating i think
like are you talking about oh you're
talking about recently like nowadays
okay okay okay okay yeah it is back a
day that i still
um
in
like investment oh yeah i was gonna say
like hp off the bat like hula and pakka
there's actual two people that created
yeah you've got bear like um
amber crumby and fitch
you've got i'm sure harrods is probably
someone's name it is uh sainsbury's lord
sainsbury yeah um
on him
sometimes when i um google randomly you
like to research like today yeah i can't
bother any of that i do that's why
you're the guy yeah you're the fun fact
guy bro because i can't bother and yeah
when you said sam was like yeah i've
researched lord sagebruy and then i
think i
went on to like kmart and obviously as
the red blood i don't know why it just
spiraled into man i can't remember the
facts but i sparred into that but yeah
man stuff like that is
don't do that man imagine if amazon was
called bezos
imagine
imagine imagine if apple was called jobs
yeah that's um yeah to be fair if it was
called that it would just be known as
that it would just be known as that but
like bezos ain't never catching on like
amazon yeah yeah it's not it's just not
it's just not um but anyway yeah that's
interesting man i need to i need them to
be released into the general public and
see how they're patterning the thing is
i would want them but for what for what
yeah for what where do i go what do i do
for them to be beneficial yeah yeah and
this is surrounded by like different
cultures like that too yeah man this 10
second delay i'm not sure about it they
didn't say 10 seconds i'm assuming this
sentence or two yeah 10 seconds isn't it
this delay i'm just not sure about it
yeah i know i'll fall you know how
socially awkward i get everybody's
standing there like a lemon i'll be
standing there silent if i'm just like
looking around and they're thinking is
he autistic
because he's not even looking at me like
he doesn't understand he's just staring
at me
waiting for the ticket
why is he like he's waiting and then
he's like
yes please
[ __ ] out um that's crazy
interesting though that is very
interesting
go on now i was gonna say if anyone has
heard of this or know more or knows more
information about it uh hit us up man
let us know well let us know what you
think about it i wonder what the 40
languages are
um
therefore is a lot there's probably all
the [ __ ] basic languages the main
basic languages there's how many
languages in the world brought to you
some i think um what's the ghanaian
language called
there are more than there's more than
one language there's tweet there's
different dialects that's the one i was
gonna say
there's there's another one there's
another popular book for life right now
i can't remember it
but that's the one i was gonna that's
the one i was thinking of yeah um fair
play man fair [ __ ] play i want that
but i don't
um
bros this is completely sidetracked
trash news oh god yeah
have you heard about um joe pete
davidson is pete davidson
no
cool right so pete davidson is like an
american comedian okay he works on
either worked or did does still well i'm
pretty sure he still works on saturday
night live you would have seen him
before just his face let me just
quickly google him
but
basically
they're [ __ ] listening to us brother
is he popped up straight away it was
like the third one down okay yeah yeah i
know him cool well i know his face here
fam
my man has body bags
like
he's hit what would okay out of ten what
would you rate him penguins wise
out of ten i've closed whole thing let
me type him in again
pete davidson
images
i mean
we're going to go off this basic picture
that's a standard pretty basic picture
yeah i'd probably give him like an i
don't know six
at best right
his name just to say he's a buzz guy
right he's not overly handsome in the
slightest yeah he's like tall and skinny
and like not overtly handsome yeah
his ex-girlfriend roster fan is a joke
he's was i'm sure he's been a couple
singers he's been with ariana grande
that's the one yeah
he's um been with um kate beckinsale
okay
he's been with um
another yeah i wouldn't necessarily
she's banging but she's got some kind of
sex appeal do you remember once upon a
time in hollywood
the hitchhiker yap with the harry
armpits that offered to suck brad pitt
off yeah he's been with her
she was just leaning on him looking up
whip
i said how old are you you already know
in your head you'll be thinking i should
really ask how old she is but you you'll
be stuttering for my tour will be
poking the back of it her head will go
like that
she'll be laying there but like do you
want a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it will smack the background as soon as
you get a donkey punch from my piece
that's a green light
do you see
but yeah and now this [ __ ] is
banging kim kardashian
sorry if um he's bang kim kardashian now
sorry yes bro
he is
it's ridiculous he's banging kim
kardashian he must have the chat fam
apparently he's got the dirk hmm so
did you know he's banging kim yeah fam
he's the he
he's he's literally the invention he's
the the patient zero of big dick energy
big dick energy was invented by hit for
him ariana grande said he's got big dick
energy and that's the first ever like
coin phrase big dick energy really from
ariana grande talk about him really yeah
yeah
nah
nah this [ __ ] is 27. he's
younger than us yeah fam
nah he's banging things
banging
what yeah bro
what yeah he's
he's given me he's given me like faith
that there is like a god
that man like kim can scoop up to wow
um
and um but he's funny because he did a
comedy special right i'm not gonna i
didn't reach for his company's special
that much okay he made one joke in there
basically said ariana grande is the
devil basically okay in that she
she invented big deck energy around him
as a manipulative spiteful thing so that
any time he fights any other girl after
him she'll be nothing but disappointed
she went around telling the whole world
that he had a big obviously he's joking
around but basically now everyone thinks
he's got a massive dick because reyna
grande said so so now he's [ __ ] all
these peng celebrities and he's like
ariana grande did this on purpose so
that any time i [ __ ] someone they'll
look at my dick and be like oh it's not
really that yeah i was like yeah i
thought it was massive yeah now
[ __ ] you now but if you're not cleaning
it for him that's wild never even knew
that he's bang chicks bro
it doesn't make any sense it really
doesn't matter and the thing is what
people are like uh is he banging kim is
he not banging him but it's like it
doesn't matter if he is the fact that
people think that he is right it's a
question it means that
he's got the nostalgia yeah it's enough
yeah because any time anyone's like um
is he here isn't he and then they're
like have you seen his ex-girlfriend's
club yes he probably is buying kim
kardashian this is ridiculous oh my god
oh my goodness yes i saw on um when i
googled it was like they just they got
spotted leaving like a dinner date or
something
so and that was yesterday and they were
a theme park together
in his ends
in that staten island or some [ __ ]
slanted buzz
so i was listening to kardashians
are we sure
you tell me about seven bro
that's what i'm saying
she's like she's 40 something ellie all
that late 30s or something yeah she
didn't give [ __ ] though she's kim
kardashian bro
what's age to kim kardashian [ __ ]
i wasn't saying it for a bad thing for
housing that's a great thing for him
yeah i know
jesus he's the luckiest guy on planet
earth bro
he's got body bags
his cv is locked tight no one can tell
them anything no one can no one can to
be fair [ __ ] no one can tell him
anything bro
oh that's what being funny in this world
gets you true that's what being funny in
this one
being funny you could look like pete
davidson and get percy and get
ridiculous [ __ ] tier one [ __ ] i can
make you cackle yeah mom
that's a grade
[ __ ]
you might say wagyu beef yeah and ever
since ariana has just been
collecting referral purse referral [ __ ]
man is
is the best thing it's not the best book
i've never had referral person to my
knowledge i'm just gonna say you might
not you might think you haven't but you
probably have like
being referral dick or referral [ __ ] is
a second nature because
to be fair teddy i have had preferably
one time who yeah i'm not gonna tell you
who obviously like
um okay cool so
the
the girl from uni that i
smashed a couple times but really didn't
like smashing her but it was just like a
uh i think i know who it is yeah one of
two but continues throwing up probably
so figure out the one so the one that
the miami one okay
that i smashed first was obviously best
friends with the other one that i
smashed after and when i smashed the
other one after she told me that she
told her that i had a big dick okay
i remember about the time trying to keep
it cool
look at her
straight up she said wow
[Music]
when she looked away i was looking to
see if you were anywhere near if anyone
was in earshot
anyone
that's his job didn't pattern though but
um yes that's to my knowledge that's the
only referral [ __ ] i've ever had um
i've
not had
i think i've had
but i don't there's not been confirmed
to me
because
i've
not intentionally by [ __ ] like you
said friends friends within the same
circle yeah yeah and if your friend's in
the same circle
you're chatting you know and you know i
[ __ ] she knows i [ __ ] her blah blah
all that stuff so it's um it's
definitely referral and there was
a chick i spoke to
um in the past but i [ __ ] her friend
in the past past as well
and she said to me
she messaged me um
way after
oh i knew everything about
unx before oh is it like
okay yeah she told me everything i was
like okay because she she followed me on
instagram out the blue didn't know who
she was but i saw he had mutuals
and obviously one of the mutuals was the
girl that i was seeing or i had seen
probably in the past
and then we got talking talking she said
yeah she told me everything i'm not [ __ ]
i've never [ __ ] this girl but
it was clear that this was a referral
yeah she was like she told me everything
it was clear
everything
you nasty bastard
but um that's hilarious the opposite
thing pops into my head or the big dick
energy as well thing put it in some head
with um
i just need to know we need to get a
girl in here at some point again um
because there's just questions i need
answered bro because i was watching have
you seen the new season big mouth no not
the other day no i honey bro i saw it
pop on my phone funny thing about that
that's so crazy i feel like sometimes
we're destined to talk about stuff yeah
because i was watching i've been
re-watching big mouth again because i've
watched it in its entirety what season
one to four but i started watching it
again and i'm just cacking in like it's
the first time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was only just this second time around
that i realized
nick and andrew the main characters
they're actually called nick and andrew
the writers of the show and they're
actually best friends yeah yeah yeah
yeah i only just deep because i i think
jessie is also called jessie oh is it
yeah and
uh
ali the asian girl yeah she's ali wong
the comedian crazy yeah that's crazy bro
because i never
tend to watch the intro after i've seen
it the first time i'm skipping so it's
time to watch it i was like oh [ __ ] nick
oh [ __ ] andrew i was like oh yeah yeah
but yeah sorry continue season five i
saw it pop up on my phone but no i've
noticed yeah because the big they're
actually based off them in it yeah so
nick is actually looks if you look at
nick kroll the career
um he does but um
what was i going to say so yeah i'll
start watching season five and there's a
bit in there
where they're all going swimming
and then it's the first time where like
the guys see the girls in that bathing
suit yeah and vice versa yeah and this
is there's this one i can't really
remember who it is there's just one kid
in there he's got he's got a [ __ ]
massive dick bro in the speedos you
could just see this massive tool bro
it's jokes
and um when they go back into their like
respective changing rooms and stuff they
start chatting and the girls come back
in and one of the girls is like
did you see my man's dick and all the
girls were like
screaming
and then i was like straight
and you could tell i finally saw a big
dick and there was just all of them were
gas yeah they didn't know what to do
with it they had got clue what to do
with it [ __ ] i need to know if that's
the tick yeah i need to know i need to
know
if galaxy big tall
and just or hear about big tall and just
think [ __ ] i need to see it i
i know it's true
that's what black's into me i know it's
true
oh to be fair you live of a girl so i
know it's true
[ __ ] i know it's true
i know it's true
that makes me wonder if i wasn't
confined into this chair oh [ __ ]
my arms would be screaming tell me sat
ng don't leave their names up tell me
satin so
i'm giddy right now so one
guy and girl that me and
bella both know
um
so go a and girl b they [ __ ]
sorry go a and guy b sorry [ __ ]
girl a has now told bella
this guy's got a totally tall
totally tall
and but this was
this was a while ago and this was when
she she wasn't checking for him none of
that
but it was one of those ones where she's
thought about it because she's seen him
like she sees him in
passing and going like yeah
rather
so obviously me and me and bella talk in
it so it's one of those ones where she's
like [ __ ]
i've heard he's got a big dick so i'm
trying to sample i'm intrigued it's
always that is that intrigue that always
gets him you know fam that's perplexing
to me because like actually to be fair i
remember i think i've said it down here
before but one of my ex-girlfriends
one of my ex-girlfriends basically knew
back in the day when i was with her we
were talking one day and there was a guy
that she knew
that i knew from basketball
and i think we saw i think it must have
been mutuals on flipping
facebook or something way back it was
way back when
and then she randomly told me one time
like ah i remember me and him were
talking one time
and i was like ugh is it and she was
like yeah nothing happened but i
remember like he invited me over one
time and i was definitely gonna go and i
was like why are we going to go she was
like um one of my friends fought him she
said he's got a big dick
and i remember thinking was that all it
took
was that you were talking about you and
this girl me and this girl was seeing
each other at that time and she told me
that we were just having a chill
conversation it didn't bother me because
i'm not friends with the guy i literally
had just played basketball against him i
wasn't his boy at all um
where made you realize but
when
she told me that i remember thinking is
that all it takes it's just hearing
donny's got a big tool for a god to like
swear
let me sample that because you could
smash a girl and be like bro she's got
the tightest poem i've ever felt and i'm
like swearing
i would never think about it again it
wouldn't make you think [ __ ] i need to
fight yeah never
never would it make me think that
it's so weird you could say bro she's
got the tightest problem i've ever felt
and i'd be like is it sick
anyway guys patreon
you just moved
i wouldn't it would never cross my mind
i wouldn't even be thinking [ __ ] i'm
jealous he got that type of like it
would never even
it wouldn't
it wouldn't even how people say it goes
in one ear out the other it won't even
make it to the other ear
but
it will ricochet off my edge i'm gonna
fly back out it wouldn't mean nothing to
me
so when i hear about this girl like oh
yeah i thought this guy's got a massive
dick and for another girl to black [ __ ]
i'm intrigued fam they always are oh
that's that's amazing to me what a world
we live in it's crazy mum it's crazy
what a world we live in
damn
this is what it is damn but yeah i've
never
to be fair like yeah i guess because
that time where i smashed those two
girls back in uni it's the only time
i've ever ever
had
even spoken to two girls who even knew
of each other
let alone anything else yeah
so
yeah it
i wouldn't be surprised if i've never
ever had repair [ __ ] from there because
no one that i've ever spoken to
consecutively of anyone we don't even
like he said like oh you said that you
and that guy had mutuals i've never
spoken to a girl
where we had mutuals of anyone else that
i even know like another female probably
guys but never never another female that
i've slept with
ever
and now i'm vexed about it
because i want that referral bro yeah
yeah referrals this is what it is isn't
it
here's what it is that's that one i
don't care anymore but
it's cool man if you were to hear about
it after the fact um you're like you're
like sick going six six unless they were
like well that was the reason but then i
found out that it was actually here yeah
that's peak but it was too late at that
point so i just went through with it
that's big that's not what you want ah
my man said
bella this guy's got a tally tool
totally tuned and she said
she bit she was intrigued intrigued
[ __ ]
it's crazy bro that's what it takes
that's literally what it takes like you
said is that what it takes yes if that's
all it takes wow
apparently
apparently we're missing the trick man
to be fair
to be fair this supports the claim as to
when we always get these among the
[ __ ] of these fan requests and then
i banged this and i went through this
group of friends and i smashed all these
girls and i'm always like no you didn't
bruv what do you mean of course you
didn't unless they've got a wham tool
maybe they did
to
i don't really like talking about my
sexual past like that
but you know you know me and you know
who i [ __ ]
and i want to say probably in
two
circumstances in my life if i can recall
i've
unintentionally [ __ ] in the same
friendship group
oh okay
and i don't know whether after [ __ ]
the first one the second one was due to
a referral um
but it still happened you know and there
was not necessarily there weren't any
qualms about it but
every party knew waguan you know yeah so
there was no beef
so yeah
it was it's it's it's weird so it could
have been very well it could have just
been the luck of the draw i don't know
damn well i hope you think it was a
referral bro because that's cool yes
it's but certainly luck of the draw is
boring
it's gonna lie to you it's boring i
remember speaking of like thinking about
i'm just like thinking about the past
and stuff like that i remember one chick
telling me
this is when we're still talking this
one back when i still live in london
i remember one chick she was telling me
um she was [ __ ] one brother
and she nearly accidentally said my name
she was like
and she had to hold herself that's him
that's disgraceful i was like first of
all why would you tell me that and the
second vote was like
how did he not like
box you and leave
you know yay
[Music]
um
yeah i'm not entirely sure
what to do with that
um yeah
i'm very much like
i don't know why i'm very much pro
bres
like i'm more i'm very much like let's
empower demand event
so when i hear stories like that
i would want to smack her regardless if
she's trying to pay me a compliment
whatever she's trying to do i don't want
to smack her in her face what was wrong
with you she told me she didn't tell me
facebook she'll never tell me yeah yeah
what's up be in the moment though man
i was banging a guy and he said your
name first of all don't tell me that i
didn't ever want to hear any sentence
that starts with i was banging another
guy
[Music]
don't ever tell me that sentence
fam don't ever tell me i know you've got
some red flags you want to go through
today red flag she tells you about the
time she fought another guy
um
that's a reflect like anna ick
altogether all together
that's hilarious but yeah man i'm very
much like
pro
dudes
and then when i hear stories about
girls like
just
john i don't know man just haphazardly
that stuff yeah
that's that's the word for it all of
that area i'm just like
[ __ ] that's not fair on here it's not
it's not as exciting you're thinking
about next things be in the moment
and you think it's cute to be out here
telling me like oh i had to like stop
myself
naughty naughty
get your [ __ ] together man
be with my man embrace him i know
um yeah it was it was a weird weird
weird thing for her to say and i didn't
even know what she expected me to things
i can't remember what i said to it i
just remembered that situation just
because we were talking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah it was weird
damn man
on that note let's go into some red
flags
[ __ ]
the thing with these red flags right
yeah the ones that we received
a lot of them are so misconceptions i
think they've forgotten that there's a
fine line between a red flag and an ick
there is a blend some of the blend yeah
don't blend them man some of the red
flags are just x i'm a read through
there's a lot so i'm gonna read through
some of them and we're gonna
put them in their right department
because some of them aren't red flags
but the first one is jokes all right go
on go on go on go on man said
well she said rather
staring at me why died during sex
[Laughter]
no no no my chest lady collapsed that
made me dizzy i laughed so hard i lost
my breath through
wow
no
no reaction you went wise
that sent me so left bro i don't think
you get it that sent me soul left
jesus christ
i can imagine the visuals just like
there just just staring at her
fam staring at me wide-eyed that's the
funniest thing there's a woman that said
that
yeah yeah women have the best everything
yeah they do they do they just is so
specific you can imagine it it's jokes
we've said it me and
women hate the fact that they're
attracted to men
nonsense humans hate the fact that
they're attracted to me because these
icks on the
we're easy we are easy
[ __ ] you know that was only the first
one oh jesus i made my back sweat fam
jesus all right i'm ready um having two
phones i remember i went through a phase
when i had two phones that's a red flag
i went through facebook but i was
working that was a work thing yeah but
hey yeah yeah yeah all that's a yeah
having two phones is a red flag for sure
wonky toes
so that's a ick that's not a red flag
it's an ick
one what
but we spoke about this
not on the pod but we've spoken about
this before when this is an ick not red
flag by the way when their next toe is
bigger than the yeah yeah so it's like
one of them ones yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was like a trigger or
something yeah 100
um
having having a new group of friends
every birthday party so having a new
group of friends at every one of our
birthdays yeah yeah yeah new besties
every single time everybody's every year
new besties yeah red flags red flag
daddy issues i think that's a green flag
for me maggie
that's a waving green flag you see the
you see the man that tell the la the
plane to land yeah these these
daddy issues is that for me come here
that's
that here because we're for the [ __ ]
yeah
oh that's hilarious uh when they dislike
anime
that's that could be a red flag
yeah fair play that's a red flag
go on
when i get a trim and they don't
compliment me
wow
facts i've been there same i've been
there bro they're acting like i look the
same i don't i'm like i'm any guy i
don't look i look clean today do you
know do you know what i hate the most
the most
all right i've gotten a trim room i know
i look clean right yeah and it's been
four or five maybe a week later yeah
four or five days a week later someone
comes up to me at work and be like oh
have you had a trim your mum yeah you're
sorry i've been walking around this with
this [ __ ] for a week now yeah yeah
you're telling me oh have you got a new
trip yeah you've seen me for the past
four days yeah [ __ ] what were you
looking at [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
fuggy yeah oh it vexes me yeah i hate it
bro i can't stand that stuff sorry me on
the day of that when i read that i was
like oh he knows my pain
he knows my pain yeah [ __ ] hate that
one
oh that was funny uh when he doesn't eat
[ __ ]
that's that's a reference that's a red
flag that's a hundred percent of red
flags you have to be eating out man you
have to eat out pack lunch man
yeah
saying all lives matter
that was jokes that's a big red flag to
be fair
yeah
fair play
when he knows his sun moon and rising i
don't even know what that means cuz i
don't know what that means what the [ __ ]
does that mean so
people have people have them like it's
like a star sign thing because i know
people have like their moons and stuff
but i don't know what this ryzen and the
sun is but i know what i know the
context in what she's trying to say
i have no idea what that means that's
alien to me what you're saying
i know the context of it i just don't
know how to explain it because i'm so
far removed from this type of
conversation okay cool because i'm so
uninterested all right i mean yeah i
know what she's trying to say
um
when she says i get along better with
guys that i do girls
agreed 100 agreed but
no butts no spots or maybes
let me
let me try and be very
unbiased and partially with that yeah go
on
i understand
when a woman says that statement purely
because
i understand how women are with women
yeah i know women are [ __ ] they're
pricks women are pricks everyone knows
that but like we said
in this one having new friendship groups
every birthday it's because you've
bitched about them all week yeah they've
got a new friendship with you yeah yeah
so it's understandable because guys
we've said this before guys think with
logic and speak with logic girls speak
and think with emotion yeah that's the
reason why they always have new
friendship groups and their best friends
always argue and blah blah stupid [ __ ]
so when they have more guy friends it's
because they can have
better conversation not necessarily
better conversations
that's because the guys are trying to
[ __ ] bro that's why they can have a
better conversation don't get me wrong
i'm thinking i'm saying it from a girl's
perspective yeah yeah
the guy she may or may not know the
guy's trying to [ __ ] her but that's not
her problem no but that's what i say
like with me the reason i say it's a red
flag because you're naive as [ __ ] oh
don't get me wrong that's why it's a red
flag for me i guess not because you're a
swagger or anything like that it's
because like if you genuinely think that
you get along with guys like when they
say i get along with guys in my
immediate head i'm thinking so you're
talking you've got more guy friends than
you have girls and eight i think these
guys are trying to bang oh i know the
thing is i know that but i can
understand
from the female people yeah yeah yeah
but yeah cool
when she has fat ankles that's an ick
that's an egg my g that's not a red flag
yeah that's what i'm saying these men
are mixing the two
i was it was that's the thing as well
guys man this is what i said i'm all
surrounding power guys because
like you said like said a second ago
like
the guy the girls always come with the
better red flags and they always come
with the best x because
for one they hate us and for two guys
make it easy and when when we put up a
post that says send us in some red flags
and you send fat ankles
that's what that's first of all this is
why we get slaughtered in these games
bro it's true that's why we're losing
indies bro this is true bro we're losing
in these streets because girls are
coming with the
they are the triple combo the triple bye
bye bye he said fat ankles is a red flag
shut up
shut up and get out of the comments bro
you don't belong here we're losing we
are losing we need to get our wits up
we're losing the battle because these
women are too funny with it from the
hilarious one too funny with it
one chick said when he owns a samsung
a what a samsung a man said samsung
samsung
i couldn't let you get away with that
i couldn't let you just carry on and
just say stuff like that
samsung when he owns a samsung to be
fair that should be a red flag no one
should be having samsung's anymore
um we've done that one before when she
knows the bouncer but is that it is that
a red flag i think that could be a bit
of a red flag i think to be fair i think
that's a red flag you think it's a red
flag more than nick yeah okay if she
knows bounces
yeah yeah that's red flag for me yeah i
feel like it's a that could be like
first date vibes
we're going out for a few drinks and
she's chatting
chatting to bouncers on a first name
basis
red flag
if he's jamaican or nigerian or god
forbid both
god forbid both the god forbid took me
out yeah to be fair yeah
when they're constantly on their phone
is that a red flag
i mean
it's a bit petty
debatable on where you're at yeah
um
following bear man who are personal
trainers
she just wants to [ __ ] man yeah she just
wants that yeah yeah yeah following bear
pts you're all slack you just want to
bang your body you just want a bad 100
understandable i get it
dodgy fake tan
flag that's more of an ick for me
true is an ick it is a nick
but it's also a flag fair play it's a
flag because
it's a flag because it's more of a
what's the word i'm looking for like a
telltale
yeah slash a
i'm not even trying to be involved with
you yeah in your friendship group oh
yeah because your friends aren't even
telling you that this dodgy tan is oh
okay this time it's dodgy yeah yeah so
if i'm being involved with you that
means you and your friends are wayward
yeah that's not a flag fair enough fair
enough fair enough fair enough
um
ah
peak
straight face when you put it in
that's tough
that's tough
that's
that's
a guy wrote that a guy wrote that
when she straight faced when you put it
in
my guy my guy he looked at himself it
was one of them he put his hand on the
on the mirror
on the window the rain was pouring
he took a deep breath
what am i fam straight face when you put
it in
oh oh that's a gut punch that is a gut
punch
damn bro mad sorry g he had to be you
yeah that is a good end though that is
oh
i feel that's more of a red flag for you
that's not red [ __ ] that's something
that she should write yeah
i'm straight face when he puts it in oh
sorry bro
i'm gonna save these ones for another
time you say you've got um x as well oh
okay cool so yeah you guys [ __ ] up
with the x and the thing this is all
right cool
listen to this guys guys listen up yeah
so
we've obviously been doing this egg
thing for a while this is how savage the
women are with the eggs that i got these
ics
from the comment section
of an ick video on tick tock guys
this is how savage these women are on
our one on one of our videos
just the comments bro
this is just the comments bro not even
submitted nothing yeah this is stuff
they thought of on the cuff i just
commented in the moment and while they
were going through tick tock
bro right this one hurt my feelings
right
so x
when he tries to merge lanes and no one
will let him in
i saw that and bellowed
that's the funniest thing i've ever read
in my entire life mine's got the lights
indicating like indicating for time for
the time their man won't even look at
him
she says she's having a passion
vagina drying up looking at you
you can't even merge lanes you're not a
man
you know what pull over and get me out
i don't even want to be in here any walk
there [ __ ]
that's shameful
[Laughter]
when he's swimming and his trunks get
inflated by the water
[Laughter]
it's literally one of the most
embarrassing things that can happen
because you've got there's nothing you
can do when you have to decompress your
trunks that's embarrassing you just got
to pull them down and the bubbles oh no
it's so annoying it's so annoying
and the pockets that the pockets are
just your floaters they the pockets
they're just there they go inside out
and they're just swinging on the table
i hate it being a guy's hard sometimes
bro it's the smartest little thing i
can't even take a dip
what what are we living in a guy can't
even take a dip a dip you know
right um when he raises his hand to call
the waiter and no one acknowledges him
yeah nah even you must see that i work
all night i agree that's a nick oh
i agree that's not fair man
when he misses the straw
this
this thing shame on you i've missed bare
times in my life the thing is sorry
when i miss it yeah i'm icked on myself
yeah yeah because you you're certain
you're about to get it i don't
when you when you miss it so bad that
you actually close your mouth over
nothing
nah
nah i have to look left or right
i remember
a chick sent me this again a while ago a
chick sent me a vid of her trying to be
sexy she had a drink in her hand she was
dressed up ready for a night out fam she
snapchat looking at the camera not
looking at a cup missed the straw
[Music]
the fact that she thinks she's buff
enough to still send that
nah
someone needs to check these women man
this is why we're losing in the war yeah
we're losing in the iq
because these men are sending this
straight fire and the guys can't
be creative enough to think of stuff
that puts them off they're so keen for
pum that nothing puts them off
them out there are so keen for pump
that's literally nothing puts them off
would make us say it's that ankle or he
can say his fat ankles oh boring it's
embarrassing that's why women can be out
here missing straws and still send the
vids because i don't give a [ __ ]
it's pathetic oh that's hilarious guys
get this together because this is a
comment section bro yeah oh
wow
i can't even compose myself to say it
when he's speaking in the group and
nobody hears him so he has to say it
again
fam
bam
group chats are the devil sometimes bro
group because group conversation is if
everyone is busting joke or everyone's
making everyone else laugh and you say
something it's just dust
you you'd want to break the phone you
want to break the phone it's so annoying
i have to double down on it when i get
ed in the group i double down
i reply to my own message i'm like so
i'm not one of the boys anymore
i'm the cat all caps so we're not boys
it's what you're telling me
everyone's airing me it's what you're
telling me
if you want me out literally let's vote
now because i will leave i don't want to
be anywhere i'm not wanted if you don't
want to be boys with me just say sorry
oh i can't stand that stuff oh my god
right um
this is what i mean so painfully
specific
when he says hi to someone and they
don't recognize him at first
bro
yeah you're you're a shadow yeah you're
not a man you're a shadow yeah
oh that's so painfully specific oh bro
when he can't find a parking spot
leave man alone yeah these men are
cutting for us when he can't find a
parking space man i got him for us
what's he supposed to do yeah i got it
for us these are guarded they hate the
i'm telling you bro women hate that
they're attracted to us
they can't [ __ ] stand it they hate
being attracted to men they actually
can't stand man oh
this one sweetened me
when he texts he
no man
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's hilarious
um this one's the oh this one's the last
one i'll wrap it up here
oh jesus christ
when he runs up the stairs and uses his
hands to climb faster
what fam like a pup when he
oh my days i imagined it and it
sweetened me i'm imagining it now he
imagined it and it sweeted me the one i
imagined as soon as i said it or as soon
as i read it was when i said in the
previous episode oh when he chases when
he's chasing after a ping pong ball i
imagine that one straight away
straight away oh
oh
you know what you know what you know
what
one is exactly like that that i used to
hate in school
you know when a rugby ball bounces and
you don't know which quiz ricochets
anywhere but you have to be alert
fam when you zig and the ball's out
i want to walk straight off the pitch
there's nothing more embarrassing than
chasing after a rugby ball and it pings
left
oh yeah there is a [ __ ] it oh there it
is no
or when you know on rugby where they do
the drop where they they drop the ball
it bounces once and then they kick it
yeah fam sometimes the ball will rick
and i'll kick in thin air i want to walk
off the pitch bro
oh my god [ __ ] it's embarrassing
being a man is so tough yes you can't
[ __ ] up once you can't get away with
stuff man said you better find a parking
spot
you better we're not [ __ ] today if
you can't even find a parking spot
what do you want from me bro what is
meant to do what is he meant to do
oh that's hilarious when he's trying to
merge lanes and no one let him in oh
if you're a man you need to be willing
to write your vehicle off to get in
there
you can't do it but then again you can't
show any
sign of frustration
you have to be cool and comically yeah
cool karma collected you have to zip zap
to the front of the thing and then you
have to find that gap one one man will
let you through won't let you in in your
blood that's fine you need to tap it
like just squeeze your thigh on the side
it's fine and then the next one you need
to force yourself in front you can't let
her see that eye that's twitching
the vexation then the fixation
and you start hold eye contact with the
person yeah whoever breaks eye contact
first loses loses straight away you they
need to know that you're willing to dent
everything to get in here this is gonna
cost me my relationship if i can't
squeeze in this lane
she's gonna leave
me it's not fair bro
oh my god [ __ ] hell man but guys the
moral of the story is we need to do
better we need to step our game up in
the game fam we got girls sending in
this that and the other video can't even
reach the straw and they're still
sending it in with chest because
they know we're not going anywhere
they know we're not going anywhere
a guy could never get away with that
couldn't
a guy could never send try to send a
sexy vid of a sip
miss the straw and then send it anyway
it's going viral blocked
viral unblock you're gonna you're gonna
see it but the next time you hear from
that girl is on i'm just bait
because you'll see her at the end you'll
see her
the recycle ticket
credit two
guys we have to do better
we're losing battle after about a week
in week out the goals are coming
always every time the proof is in the
views every time we post a video what
gives guys the ick
it does well we're talking two to three
hundred thousand
views does well every time we do a woman
one 1.5 million 1.9 million yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's kicking off we're losing
guys women just they just know what they
want off the cough cutthroat cutthroat
they've been waiting for days like this
oh
no one even asked
no one asked for the contribution listen
let me continue this list
they said that more needs to be said
oh it's not fair guys we need to do
better so guys please put your thinking
caps on and let's think of some icks and
some red flags that we can actually
bring to production yeah man
and just just level the playing field
here because week in week out it's we're
just getting bullied bro every day man
the best we can do is fat ankles what is
that
that's what is that i put it in there
purposely because i was like i was so
underwhelmed and disappointed by it
so underwhelmed it's like what what were
you meant to do with that there's
nothing what are we making it's the same
words it's not
literally just the same words
so
do better guys please do better women
that's a shame and then women take a day
off yeah take it easy you know just for
today
love your man in it
love your man please him yeah tell him
something you like about him today it's
going to be hard
just one thing just try just you're not
even noticing today this week
just tell him one thing that you really
like about him
please and even if you're in a talking
stage with a guy or even if you've got a
male friend tell him one thing he does
that's a turn on or that you like about
him because
it's too easy for you man to find eggs
it's concerning you just pick them out
bro it just comes
they store it bro yeah they see it and
then they store it yeah
they just never forget wait for the day
for the group chat to just be like okay
and they just dash it in there yeah
they've got thousands of them yeah we
haven't even said the same one twice we
haven't we've been doing this for weeks
we haven't we've never said the same one
twice
guys are always sending in the same way
same [ __ ] you're boring
guys do better the [ __ ] that they do
wrong we need to expose it man because
we're losing we're [ __ ]
you're losing oh man anyway let's run
them by the [ __ ] and then um wrap
this [ __ ] up
so
okay
so we've got one here man said am i the
[ __ ] for sleeping with this chick and
then her mom
yes
so
the story goes i like how we said that
the story goes i was meeting up with
this girl who lives across from my work
stupid fine so i actually made the
effort to come to her
i get her apartment and she introduces
me to her equally if not more attractive
milf
of a mother
i introduce myself have a chat and she
cuts it short and yanks me into her room
i think this is the girl
i think this is the girl
it has to be the girl we do the nasty
i blow her back out done in about 20.
i'm glad i appreciate the honesty with
that one
done in about 20.
and she immediately just lies in bed
after and just says
i you can leave now and falls asleep
props props to the chick perhaps a chick
who's willing to get her nut and kick
man out yeah sometimes guys love that we
we do we do love them we do
so i chucked my pants back on and i'm
walking out to where her mum was and she
calls me out saying so you just smashing
and passing
i panic a bit but tell her like nah
she put the girls in he put the girl's
name but i'm not gonna say it she's
fallen asleep and said to let myself out
long story short the mom started
chatting saying oh so you're into older
girls
this girl's 24 and i'm 19 to which i
reply of course
moving on we [ __ ]
at one point against her door her
daughter's door and the kitchen counter
the daughter then walked out and saw her
naked mom on the couch and me pulling my
clothes on
she just turned around slowly and went
into her room
and i hit legs out the apartment
that was going so well until he started
missing some information bro
the deception in this
[Music]
deception
oh man all right first of all bro thank
you for the message appreciate it but
none of this happened
let's just address the elephant in the
room none of this happened oh my
goodness
it
it started off so well
it really started off strong bro it
started off so i believe the first bit i
believed it up until she's off up and up
until and after she said
i'm tired get your [ __ ] bounce
that one everything was believable
everything was everything was believable
he even said he lasted a young 20 which
is admirable but not a long time
um
she even said she fell asleep and said
get out
also probably quite factual man i'm
loving this she's a little bit older
than you i'm loving them loving and
loving the ma even the mom saying what
you're just smashing and passing oh okay
it's a bit sticky my said he even
hesitated and was like nah nah nah she
just fell asleep i believed all of it
and then you said you banged the mum
against the girl's door
like while she's asleep in a bedroom no
you didn't no you didn't no big listen
to me but no
you did do you did in this cap
just cut out the scouts it's the cappy's
cab
farm just
just where it is yeah
you were doing really really well you
are
you are you could have even submitted
the thing saying ah am i bad for banging
this girl and really wanting to bang
their mom or that one right
or what it would have been more
believable but the fact that you just
said
that you banged the mum prove it my g
that's it prove it because
the reason why i
agree why i think it's a lie is because
you gave so much context up until the
right get your [ __ ] you can leave
because i'm tired of bust man or
whatever and then you start talking to
the mom hesitant and then he said
something what did he say he said
something like moving on before moving
on we fight like where's the story how
did this go from here today
like how you've explained everything
about the girl
but then the mum you just said oh she
she said this and then okay yeah we
[ __ ]
didn't happen i didn't know didn't
happen i'm sorry but it didn't happen
you [ __ ] against the door and you
[ __ ] on the on the kitchen cabinet and
then the door came out and she just
turned around the water turned around
and watched the mum was just stalkers on
the sofa it didn't happen oh my god bro
nah bro no bro it didn't happen there's
this is movie chat
it didn't happen right bro it literally
didn't happen
let's say it did okay cool less
entertaining let's entertain it for a
second and let's say it did happen
there's a lot of flags going on because
as soon as you said
the daughter walked in saw while gwan
and just span around and turn back this
has happened many times before this is
happening every wednesday the mum's a
freak the daughters are freaked they're
both nowhere it is where it is
and she's like the daughter is like ah
not again
she can't the mom can't help the fact
that she's banging cool
the daughter can't help the fact that
she's also banging
but the mom is just different you know
the mom's different that's the reason
why he
had to have that conversation i'm sorry
i can't entertain this
i can't obtain this [ __ ] i better
worry about crying but i don't know i'm
really trying i just don't know where
else i can take it oh i'm really trying
bro i'm really trying i can't entertain
this [ __ ] for one second
these guys were coming off the thing
sorry guys that's pissed me he's a
[ __ ] liar
i'm lucky enough to sing man
is [ __ ] [ __ ] man head on over to
patreon.com
[Music]
you